In May, a leaked draft of a Supreme Court decision indicated that the court might soon overturn 50 years of legal precedent and strike down Roe v. Wade, the 1973 ruling that found there is a constitutional right to abortion. Dozens of states are poised to outlaw or dramatically restrict abortion if Roe is overturned. While the court has yet to issue a final ruling, we're going to talk today about one aspect of what a post-row future would look like. What could happen to the mental health and well-being of people who are no longer able to access abortion? Abortion opponents have long argued that the procedure harms women's mental health and that it leads to depression, anxiety, regret, and even post-traumatic stress disorder.
5月，一份泄露的最高法院裁决草案显示，法院可能很快会推翻50年的法律先例，废除1973年的“罗诉韦德案”裁决，该裁决确立了宪法规定的堕胎权。如果“罗诉韦德案”被推翻，数十个州准备取缔或大幅限制堕胎。虽然法院尚未发布最终裁决，但我们今天将讨论“后罗诉韦德时代”的一个方面。那些无法获得堕胎服务的人，其心理健康和福祉会发生什么？堕胎反对者长期以来一直认为，堕胎手术会损害女性的心理健康，并导致抑郁、焦虑、后悔，甚至创伤后应激障碍。
But years of research have failed to find that abortion itself causes these outcomes. So how does obtaining an abortion or being denied one affect mental health and well-being? What are the effects of laws that limit access to abortion, such as those that mandate waiting periods or pre-abortion counseling? And how might new laws that outlaw abortion affect people, even in parts of the country, where abortion remains legal? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. Our guest today is Dr. Antonia Biggs, a social psychologist and associate professor at the advancing new standards in reproductive health program at the University of California, San Francisco.
但多年的研究未能发现堕胎本身会导致这些后果。那么，进行堕胎或被拒绝堕胎如何影响心理健康和福祉？限制堕胎的法律（例如强制等待期或堕胎前咨询）有什么影响？即使在堕胎仍然合法的地区，新的堕胎禁令又会如何影响人们？欢迎收听美国心理学会的旗舰播客《心理学谈话》，该节目探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯。我们今天的嘉宾是安东尼娅·比格斯博士，她是社会心理学家，也是加州大学旧金山分校“推进生殖健康新标准”项目的副教授。
Dr. Biggs studies the mental health effects of abortion. She led the mental health analysis for the Turnaway study, a nationwide examination of the health and well-being of women who seek abortions. She also researches the challenges people face when accessing sexual and reproductive health services, as well as public attitudes toward abortion, particularly medication-induced abortion. Thank you for joining me, Dr. Biggs. Hi, thank you so much for having me. So excited to be here. As I mentioned a moment ago, abortion opponents often argue that abortion is in itself bad for people's mental health and can lead to many negative mental health outcomes. The turnaway study on which
比格斯博士研究堕胎对心理健康的影响。她领导了“拒之门外研究”（Turnaway Study）的心理健康分析，这是一项针对寻求堕胎女性的健康和福祉的全国性调查。她还研究人们在获取性和生殖健康服务时面临的挑战，以及公众对堕胎（特别是药物流产）的态度。感谢您参加我们的节目，比格斯博士。嗨，非常感谢邀请我。很高兴来到这里。正如我刚才提到的，堕胎反对者经常争辩说，堕胎本身对人们的心理健康有害，并可能导致许多负面的心理健康后果。你们参与的“拒之门外研究”
you worked, address this question directly. Would you start by telling us about that study how it was conducted and what it found? Sure. So the turnaway study is a national study that was led by my colleague, Dr. Diana Green Foster at ECSF. And in this study, the impetus behind this study really came from this idea that abortion harms women's mental health. This is something that Justice Kennedy had stated in the Gonzalez v. Carhart case where he literally said that we don't have reliable data to measure the phenomenon, but that it seems unexceptional to conclude that some women come to regret their abortion and that severe depression and low self-esteem is going to follow. So this is an assumption that has been integrated in a lot of the state. level restrictions on abortion, yet he clearly states that we don't have reliable data. So the turnaway study really aimed to provide that reliable data. So it's one of the most rigorous
直接解决了这个问题。您能先给我们介绍一下这项研究吗？它是如何进行的，发现了什么？当然。 “拒之门外研究”是一项由我在加州大学旧金山分校的同事戴安娜·格林·福斯特博士领导的全国性研究。这项研究的动力实际上源于“堕胎损害女性心理健康”这一观点。肯尼迪大法官在“冈萨雷斯诉卡哈特案”中曾明确表示，虽然我们没有可靠的数据来衡量这一现象，但得出“一些女性会后悔堕胎，并随之产生严重抑郁和自卑感”的结论似乎是理所当然的。因此，这是一个被整合到许多州级堕胎限制中的假设，但他明确表示我们没有可靠的数据。所以，“拒之门外研究”旨在提供这些可靠的数据。它是我们研究该问题时最严谨的
studies that we have studying that question. So we recruited nearly a thousand women and followed them for five years. And we compared people who had an abortion to people who were denied an abortion because they were just above a facility facility's gestational age limit. And we recruited people across the U.S., and we were really able to assess whether the people who had an abortion were at increased risk of having negative mental health outcomes when compared to the people who were denying an abortion. And what we found is that this assumption is wrong. that we found that people who had an abortion were at no, they were not at an increased risk of experiencing depression, anxiety, suicidal ideation, post-traumatic stress disorder.
研究之一。我们招募了近一千名女性，并对她们进行了五年的跟踪调查。我们将那些堕胎的人与那些因刚好超过医疗机构孕周限制而被拒绝堕胎的人进行了比较。我们在全美范围内招募了参与者，并能够评估与被拒绝堕胎的人相比，堕胎的人是否面临更高的负面心理健康后果风险。我们发现这个假设是错误的。我们发现，堕胎的人在经历抑郁、焦虑、自杀意念、创伤后应激障碍方面并没有增加风险。
So we looked at all of those outcomes and we did not find an increased risk among the women who had abortion. But what we did find is that the women who were denying an abortion did have short-term elevated levels of stress, anxiety, low life-satisfaction. and low self-esteem when compared to the women who were able to get their wanted abortion. So, in fact, we found the opposite of what people were assuming. And then the other thing we found is that women, most women do not regret their abortion. Actually, we found that nearly 99% of women, when we follow them for over five years, say that the abortion was the right position for them. Okay, so you're a psychologist and you focused on the men,
我们观察了所有这些结果，并没有发现堕胎女性的风险增加。但我们确实发现，与能够获得所需堕胎服务的女性相比，被拒绝堕胎的女性在短期内确实有更高的压力、焦虑、生活满意度低和自卑感。事实上，我们发现的结果与人们假设的恰恰相反。我们发现的另一件事是，大多数女性并不后悔堕胎。事实上，我们发现近99%的女性在五年多的跟踪调查中表示，堕胎对她们来说是正确的决定。好的，您是一位心理学家，在分析“拒之门外”数据时专注于心理
health outcomes in the analyses of the turnaway data. But the study also looked at other outcomes like physical health and the economic effects of getting or being denied an abortion. What were some of the highlights of those findings? Yeah. So what we found, when we look at all the other outcomes that we looked at, we found that the people who were denying abortion were much more likely to experience economic hardship and economic insecurity that lasted for years. This impacted the financial well-being of the people who were denying abortion as well as their children and families, so they were much more likely to live in poverty. We also found that people who were experiencing intimate partner violence were significantly more likely to be tethered to those
健康结果。但该研究还观察了其他结果，如身体健康以及堕胎或被拒绝堕胎的经济影响。这些发现中有哪些亮点？是的。当我们观察所有其他结果时，我们发现被拒绝堕胎的人更有可能经历持续多年的经济困难和经济不安全感。这影响了被拒绝堕胎者的财务状况以及她们的孩子和家庭，因此她们更有可能生活在贫困中。我们还发现，经历亲密伴侣暴力的人更有可能在多年内被束缚在这些
partners over years, the people who were denying an abortion were more likely to stay in contact with those violent partners than the people who were able to get their abortions. And then from a physical health perspective, we also, we know that abortion is much safer than childbirth. And in the turnaway study, we found that people who were denied an abortion and carried those pregnancies to term, were much more likely to experience hypertension, chronic pain. They had a greater likelihood of poor health compared to those who have received an abortion. And then most tragically, we actually had two people who died in childbirth of the women who were denying abortion. And that's really an astronomical number when you think of the number
伴侣身边，与能够堕胎的人相比，被拒绝堕胎的人更有可能与那些暴力的伴侣保持联系。从身体健康的角度来看，我们也知道堕胎比分娩安全得多。在“拒之门外研究”中，我们发现被拒绝堕胎并足月分娩的人更有可能患上高血压、慢性疼痛。与接受堕胎的人相比，她们健康状况不佳的可能性更大。最悲惨的是，在被拒绝堕胎的女性中，实际上有两人死于分娩。考虑到我们研究中包含的人数，这是一个惊人的数字。
of people that we included in this study. And nobody who had an abortion. died. So we found, you know, very severe consequences to their physical health. What are the biggest challenges of doing this type of research? Was it hard to collect the sample? Was it difficult to structure the questions in a way that would get you what you needed? Tell us about that. Well, I think that one of the reasons why we haven't had good data up until the turnaway study is because of the challenges conducting this kind of research. So you can't randomize people to an abortion group or not abortion group ethically for obvious reasons. And so that has led to a lot of correlational studies that don't take into account some of, some important factors that could predispose people to negative mental health outcomes.
而堕胎的人中没有人死亡。所以我们发现，这对她们的身体健康造成了非常严重的后果。做这类研究最大的挑战是什么？收集样本难吗？以一种能得到所需结果的方式构建问题是否困难？请告诉我们。嗯，我认为直到“拒之门外研究”之前我们一直没有好的数据，原因之一就是进行此类研究的挑战。出于显而易见的原因，你不能在伦理上将人们随机分配到堕胎组或非堕胎组。因此，这导致了许多相关性研究，这些研究没有考虑到可能使人们容易产生负面心理健康结果的一些重要因素。
So what was unique about this study is that my colleague, Dr. Diana Green Foster, was brave enough to do the study that nobody thought she could do, which is to interview people who are denied an abortion at the time of being denied an abortion. So, you know, people didn't think that she could do it, but she did with the help of amazing clinics who helped with the recruitment. It was that the idea was spawned by a colleague of mine who's a clinician, Dr. Eleanor Dre, who knew that women were being turned away and was wanting to know what happens to those people. So that prompted the study design and it was a tremendous amount of work involved all the clinics who helped to recruit. And then we followed people for five years interviewing them every six months, so 11 waves of interviews.
这项研究的独特之处在于，我的同事戴安娜·格林·福斯特博士有勇气去做没人认为她能做到的研究，即在人们被拒绝堕胎时采访她们。所以，人们认为她做不到，但在帮助招募的优秀诊所的协助下，她做到了。这个想法是由我的同事、临床医生埃莉诺·德雷博士提出的，她知道女性被拒之门外，并想知道这些人会发生什么。这促成了研究设计，涉及所有协助招募的诊所，工作量巨大。然后我们跟踪了人们五年，每六个月采访她们一次，共11轮采访。
So it was a huge, tremendous amount of work and involved a multidisciplinary team of everything. experts, clinicians, stemographers, epidemiologists, which is one of the strengths of the study, but also a challenging study to conduct. What were the limitations? I mean, if you could have done an ideal study with no limitations,
这是一项极其繁重的工作，涉及一个由专家、临床医生、超声技师、流行病学家组成的多学科团队，这是该研究的优势之一，但也是一项具有挑战性的研究。局限性是什么？我的意思是，如果你能进行一项没有局限性的理想研究，
what would it have looked like compared to what you had to do? So every study has its limitations. I think in terms of this particular study design, I think it's one of the best. It sort of takes advantage of a quasi-experimental design. One of the limitations is that more people did participate. So our participation, you know, ideally you want everyone to participate, but of course that's never going to be possible. So I'm not sure what we would have done differently other than in terms of getting more people to participate.
与你必须做的事情相比，它会是什么样子？每项研究都有其局限性。我认为就这种特定的研究设计而言，它是最好的。它利用了一种准实验设计。局限性之一是参与的人数。理想情况下，你希望每个人都参与，但这当然是不可能的。除了在让更多人参与方面，我不确定我们会有什么不同的做法。
I think in retrospect, there's probably like tweaks that we would have done to our survey instrument. But overall, I think it's a study that we're all very proud of. There's another idea that's often cited by abortion opponents that many women come to. regret having had an abortion. What does the research say about abortion and regret? So the research says that, well, the turnaway study research says that most people do not regret their abortions. Ninety-nine percent of women say that the abortion was the right decision for them, and this continues over five years. We also have a lot of, research from other studies that have looked at women. So my colleague, Dr. Katrina Kemport,
回想起来，我们可能会对调查工具进行一些微调。但总的来说，我认为这是一项我们都引以为豪的研究。堕胎反对者经常引用另一个观点，即许多女性后悔堕胎。研究对堕胎和后悔有什么说法？研究表明，“拒之门外研究”表明大多数人并不后悔堕胎。99%的女性表示堕胎对她们来说是正确的决定，这种情况持续了五年。我们还有很多来自其他研究的研究，这些研究观察了女性。所以我的同事卡特里娜·肯波特博士，
has done interviews with people who said that they had emotional, really specifically trying to find people who may have regretted their abortions. And it was very hard to find those people. But when she did, she conducted, I think, 17 interviews. And what she found, was that it wasn't that people were regretting the abortion itself. It was that people were regretting the circumstances around the abortion. So there's something that we call decisional regret versus situational regret, which is a term that a colleague of mine, Katie Watson, wrote a paper about. And the idea is, in the case of abortion, is that you wish you were in that circumstance that led you to need an abortion.
采访了那些说自己有情绪的人，专门试图寻找可能后悔堕胎的人。找到这些人非常困难。但当她找到时，她进行了17次采访。她发现，人们后悔的并不是堕胎本身。人们后悔的是堕胎周围的环境。所以我们称之为“决策性后悔”与“情境性后悔”，这是我的同事凯蒂·沃森写的一篇论文中的术语。这个想法是，在堕胎的情况下，你希望自己没有处于导致你需要堕胎的那种境地。
You wish that maybe your partner reacted differently and was more supportive, or you wish that you had better financial circumstances, or you were more stable housing. There are situations in your life that you wish were different so that you could have that and carry that pregnancy to term. And so there's regret about that. And really, it's very rare that people are regretting that they actually had the abortion once they had no other option. Now, you've also done research into the reasons why women seek abortions. What are some of the most common reasons?
你可能希望你的伴侣反应不同，更支持你，或者你希望你有更好的经济状况，或者你有更稳定的住房。你生活中有些情况是你希望不同的，这样你就可以拥有并足月分娩。所以对此有后悔。实际上，一旦人们别无选择，很少有人会后悔自己真的堕胎了。现在，您还研究了女性寻求堕胎的原因。最常见的原因有哪些？
And do they differ from what most people think? Well, women have abortions for many reasons. Often there's more than one reason for them choosing to have an abortion. But I don't know that they differ from why people think. The most common reason is financial reasons, economic reasons, not being having the right financial circumstances to raise a child. Many women are concerned about their existing children and want to, you know, they want to provide a better life than they think they can provide for that child at the time.
它们与大多数人想的不同吗？嗯，女性堕胎的原因有很多。通常她们选择堕胎的原因不止一个。但我不知道它们与人们认为的原因有什么不同。最常见的原因是财务原因、经济原因，没有足够的经济条件来抚养孩子。许多女性担心她们现有的孩子，并希望提供比她们认为当时能为那个孩子提供的更好的生活。
some choose to have an abortion due to partner-related reasons they're not with the right partner and yeah lots of different reasons have those reasons changed over time they tend to be the same reasons that people people um any reason why it might not be a good time to have carry a pregnancy to term tends to be the reason why people have an abortion, and that hasn't really changed over time.
有些人因为伴侣相关的原因选择堕胎，她们没有合适的伴侣，是的，有很多不同的原因。这些原因随着时间的推移而改变了吗？它们往往是人们认为不适合足月分娩的相同原因，这往往是人们堕胎的原因，这一点并没有随着时间的推移而真正改变。
What has the availability of medication-induced abortion done to change the landscape out there? Are we seeing more women accessing that type of treatment as opposed to surgical abortion? Yeah, we've seen tremendous growth in the provision of medication abortion. now it's over half of people, of half of abortions are medication abortions, and it needs to be much lower. I think that in part that has to do with now we have telemedicine provision of medication abortions. So particularly during the pandemic, telemedicine became available in the case of medication abortion, so more people are able to access it. People prefer, in some cases, people prefer medication abortion because it feels more natural or more private.
药物流产的普及在改变现状方面做了什么？我们是否看到更多的女性在接受这种治疗，而不是手术流产？是的，我们看到药物流产的提供有了巨大的增长。现在超过一半的堕胎是药物流产，而且这个比例还需要更低。我认为这在一定程度上与我们现在有了药物流产的远程医疗服务有关。特别是在疫情期间，远程医疗在药物流产方面变得可用，因此更多人能够获得它。在某些情况下，人们更喜欢药物流产，因为它感觉更自然或更私密。
They would prefer to carry, you know, to pass a pregnancy, be at home at the time. So, but then there's, of course, people who prefer in in-clinic procedure as well. How much do we know about the children who were born to women who had wanted to have an abortion but were unable to obtain one? What happens to them? And are most of them adopted? Do mothers tend to keep them? Or is this just an area that needs more study? Well, in the turnaway study, we looked at the people who were denied an abortion and carried those pregnancies to term.
他们更喜欢在家中完成流产过程。当然，也有人更喜欢诊所内的手术。我们对那些想要堕胎但无法获得堕胎的女性所生的孩子了解多少？他们发生了什么？他们大多数被收养了吗？母亲倾向于抚养他们吗？还是这只是一个需要更多研究的领域？嗯，在“拒之门外研究”中，我们观察了那些被拒绝堕胎并足月分娩的人。
And we looked at the outcomes of those children. So they were significantly more likely to live in poverty, as I had mentioned before. Very few place those children up for adoption. that was a very uncommon scenario. So this idea that has been purported that adoption is going to take the place of access to abortion is not evidence-based. We know that that is very unlikely to happen. We also saw very sadly and tragically that the people who were denying an abortion carried those pregnancy to term were less likely to bond with that child.
我们观察了这些孩子的结果。正如我之前提到的，他们更有可能生活在贫困中。很少有人将这些孩子送去收养，这是一种非常罕见的情况。因此，那种认为收养将取代堕胎服务的观点是没有证据支持的。我们知道这种情况发生的可能性很小。我们还非常悲伤和痛苦地看到，那些被拒绝堕胎并足月分娩的人与孩子的联系较少。
So we looked at indicators of maternal bonding, and that was lower. And we also saw that the existing children were less likely to reach those classic developmental milestones that are measured, and they weren't quite reaching the same milestones. So the impacts for the children are very real. She talked about existing children, meaning that a lot of these women already had children and the children that they had were also affected by the outcome, the fact that the woman couldn't get an abortion. That's right. Yeah. So the entire families are affected, including the ones who were already in the household. And that is one of the important reasons why people want an abortion, too, is that they're thinking about their other children and families.
所以我们观察了母婴联系的指标，结果较低。我们还看到，现有的孩子不太可能达到那些被测量的经典发育里程碑，他们没有达到同样的里程碑。所以对孩子的影响是非常真实的。她谈到了现有的孩子，这意味着许多女性已经有了孩子，她们所拥有的孩子也受到了影响，即女性无法堕胎的事实。没错。是的。整个家庭都受到了影响，包括已经在家庭中的成员。这也是人们想要堕胎的重要原因之一，因为她们在考虑她们的其他孩子和家庭。
Many states already have laws mandating that people undergo a waiting period or counseling before they can have an abortion. How do those kinds of requirements affect women's access to abortion? And then how do they affect the women's mental health afterward? Yeah, well, it's really interesting that these mandated waiting period and mandated counseling laws are passed with this idea that they're going to protect women from harm, protect them from physical harm and mental health harm in Texas. One of the women are required to receive this a booklet that warrants them of an increased risk of becoming suicidal.
许多州已经有法律规定人们在堕胎前必须经历等待期或咨询。这些要求如何影响女性获得堕胎的机会？它们如何影响女性之后的心理健康？是的，很有趣的是，这些强制等待期和强制咨询法律的通过是基于这样一种想法，即它们将保护女性免受伤害，保护她们免受身体伤害和心理健康伤害。在德克萨斯州，女性被要求收到一本小册子，警告她们自杀风险增加。
And these, the idea that they're going to protect people's mental health is definitely not based in evidence. And we see that, as I just shared, it's very much quite the opposite. But what's really, really hard to stomach with these laws is that they're not thinking about what kind of mental health risks are they. So they're saying they're protecting people from mental health harm, but they may also be increasing mental health harm. And we did some work where we looked at the people who had to overcome burdens accessing care and what those associations were with mental health symptoms. And we found that people who had to overcome barriers accessing care, so traveling far, who had trouble finding a clinic and other obstacles, they were more likely to experience
这些认为它们会保护人们心理健康的观点绝对不是基于证据的。正如我刚才分享的那样，我们看到情况恰恰相反。但这些法律中最让人难以接受的是，它们根本没有考虑心理健康风险是什么。所以它们声称在保护人们免受心理健康伤害，但它们实际上可能正在增加心理健康伤害。我们做了一些工作，观察了那些必须克服获取护理负担的人，以及这些负担与心理健康症状之间的联系。我们发现，必须克服获取护理障碍的人，比如长途跋涉、难以找到诊所和其他障碍，她们更有可能经历
symptoms of stress, anxiety, and depression, than people who didn't have to overcome those obstacles. And the other thing that we found is that lack of autonomy, so being forced to wait, which is what is required in a mandated waiting period law, being forced to wait after you've made a decision is also associated with more stress, anxiety, and depression. So these laws are harmful to people's mental health and do the opposite of what they claim to do. You've studied the role that stigma plays in how women experience abortion and how they feel about it afterward. Can you talk about that? Yeah.
压力、焦虑和抑郁症状，而不是那些不必克服这些障碍的人。我们发现的另一件事是缺乏自主权，即被迫等待（这是强制等待期法律所要求的），在做出决定后被迫等待也与更多的压力、焦虑和抑郁有关。因此，这些法律对人们的心理健康有害，并且与它们声称的作用背道而驰。您研究了污名化在女性经历堕胎以及之后对堕胎的感受中所起的作用。您能谈谈吗？是的。
So we, in the Tunaway City, we looked at people, we asked people whether they felt that their community or people close to them would look down on them if they knew they had an abortion and the vast majority said that they did. So perceived abortion stigma was pervasive. And then when we looked to see those who experienced perceived abortion stigma and their mental health outcomes years later, we found that those who perceived more stigma were significantly more likely to experience psychological distress in the five years after having sought or been denied an abortion. And I would think that that would be part of the reason that it's so hard to get the sample, right? I mean, just the stigma associated with getting the abortion is, it was hard enough going to get the abortion, right? And now a researcher
在“拒之门外研究”中，我们询问人们是否觉得如果她们的社区或亲近的人知道她们堕胎，会看不起她们，绝大多数人表示确实如此。因此，感知的堕胎污名化是普遍存在的。当我们观察那些经历过感知堕胎污名化的人及其多年后的心理健康结果时，我们发现那些感知到更多污名化的人在寻求或被拒绝堕胎后的五年内，更有可能经历心理困扰。我想这会是样本如此难获得的部分原因，对吧？我的意思是，仅仅是堕胎相关的污名化，去堕胎就已经够难了，对吧？现在研究人员
wants to talk to you about how you feel. That's got to be tough. Yeah, I think that, I mean, we found that many people actually enjoyed sharing their stories because this might be the, that the interviewer may be the only person that they could share their stories with due to stigma. So, for some people, I think that it was a good reprieve to be able to be with people who aren't going to judge you about your abortion and actually be interested in your experience. And then in other cases, we would ask them so many questions about the abortion. And we heard from the interviewers that they said they never thought about their abortion until we picked up the phone and called them because it's something that they sort of had moved on and weren't really thinking about it. If Roe is overturned, what kinds of effects do you anticipate we're going to see on women who live in parts of the country where abortion remains legal? And what about where it's illegal? I mean, you know, we've already got a mental health crisis in this country. What do you believe? And maybe this is unfair because you haven't done the research yet. But I mean, what would you anticipate as a researcher would be the outcome? Well, we expect, if we're always overturned, we expect that half the country is going to lose access to abortion, which is, which means that more women are going to need to travel out of state to get an abortion, or that more women are going to choose to self-manage their abortion, so have an abortion on their own without.
想和你谈谈你的感受。那一定很难。是的，我认为，我们发现许多人实际上喜欢分享她们的故事，因为采访者可能是唯一一个因为污名化而能与她们分享故事的人。所以，对一些人来说，我认为能够与那些不会因为堕胎而评判你，并且实际上对你的经历感兴趣的人在一起，是一种很好的解脱。在其他情况下，我们会问她们很多关于堕胎的问题。我们从采访者那里听说，她们说在我们要打电话给她们之前，她们从未想过自己的堕胎，因为这是她们已经走出来，并没有真正去想的事情。如果“罗诉韦德案”被推翻，你预计在堕胎仍然合法的地区，女性会受到什么影响？在堕胎非法的地区呢？我的意思是，你知道，我们国家已经有了心理健康危机。你认为会怎样？也许这不公平，因为你还没有做过研究。但作为一名研究人员，你预计结果会是什么？嗯，我们预计，如果“罗诉韦德案”被推翻，我们预计半个国家将失去堕胎机会，这意味着更多的女性将需要跨州去堕胎，或者更多的女性将选择自行管理堕胎，即在没有
out clinical assistance. This may be something that is likely to be much safer than in pre-row years in that people, many people will have access to medication abortion, but some may not. I mean, some may choose to use physical methods. And then the other outcome is that more people are going to carry to term, which we already know is riskier physically and can lead to a host of negative outcomes. as we found in the turnaway study. I worry about the lack of bodily autonomy that this decision means for people.
临床协助的情况下自行堕胎。这可能比“罗诉韦德案”之前的情况要安全得多，因为许多人将能够获得药物流产，但有些人可能无法获得。我的意思是，有些人可能会选择使用物理方法。另一个结果是，更多的人将足月分娩，我们已经知道这在身体上风险更大，并可能导致一系列负面后果，正如我们在“拒之门外研究”中发现的那样。我担心这项裁决对人们意味着缺乏身体自主权。
It means that they are being denied a right to exercise their own bodily autonomy and being forced to travel or forced to carry to term or forced to end the pregnancy on their own. When they may prefer to have clinical assistance. So I think this is going to push people later in pregnancy. It's going to force more travel and it's going to negatively impact in particular people who have fewer resources, whether that's financial resources or emotional resources. And I also worry about people being criminalized. people who self-manage their abortions are at risk of being criminalized. And then we know that certain groups of people are more likely to be targeted by the criminal
这意味着她们被剥夺了行使自身身体自主权的权利，被迫长途跋涉，或被迫足月分娩，或被迫自行终止妊娠。而她们可能更希望获得临床协助。所以我认为这将把人们推向更晚的孕期。这将迫使更多的人长途跋涉，并将对那些资源较少的人产生负面影响，无论是经济资源还是情感资源。我还担心人们被定罪。自行管理堕胎的人面临被定罪的风险。我们知道某些群体更容易成为刑事
justice system. And so there are a lot of things that I worry. But I also think that maybe this is going to have an increase abortion stigma. So I think if abortion is illegal, does that mean that more people are going to think that being against abortion is, I don't know, are people, our attitudes about abortion? Or could those change and will people be judged more for seeking abortion? I don't know. Those are things I don't know. So what are the biggest questions you think researchers still need to answer about abortion and mental health?
司法系统的目标。所以有很多事情让我担心。但我还认为，这可能会增加堕胎的污名化。所以我想，如果堕胎是非法的，那是否意味着更多的人会认为反对堕胎是……我不知道，人们对堕胎的态度会改变吗？或者人们会因为寻求堕胎而受到更多评判吗？我不知道。这些是我不知道的事情。那么你认为研究人员在堕胎和心理健康方面还需要回答的最大问题是什么？
So we know that for most people, the population level, abortion, it doesn't increase people's risk for mental health harm. But there's some people who may need support. but what we know very little about is what is the impact of all of these the structural stigma and these laws and these increased barriers and all the obstacles that people need to overcome. I feel like we need more work to understand how that might negatively impact people. There's some qualitative work that shows that overcoming these barriers can be very traumatic. and I think that's something that I would want to understand
我们知道，对于大多数人来说，在人口层面，堕胎并不会增加人们心理健康受损的风险。但有些人可能需要支持。但我们知之甚少的是，所有这些结构性污名化、这些法律、这些增加的障碍以及人们需要克服的所有障碍的影响是什么。我觉得我们需要做更多的工作来了解这可能会如何对人们产生负面影响。有一些定性研究表明，克服这些障碍可能会非常痛苦。我认为这是我想了解的
who is more effective from a mental health perspective. Well, Dr. Biggs, I want to thank you so much for joining me today. This has been very interesting. Thank you. Thank you for having me. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at www.spokenof psychology.org. We're on Apple, Stitcher, or wherever you get your podcasts.
从心理健康的角度来看，谁受到的影响更大。好的，比格斯博士，非常感谢您今天参加我的节目。这非常有趣。谢谢。谢谢邀请我。您可以在我们的网站 www.spokenof psychology.org 上找到《心理学谈话》的往期节目。我们也在 Apple、Stitcher 或您获取播客的任何地方。
If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org. Speaking of Psychology is produced by Lee Wynerman. Our sound editor is Chris Condihan. Thank you for listening. For the American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
如果您对未来的播客有评论或想法，可以发送电子邮件至 speaking of psychology at APA.org。《心理学谈话》由李·温纳曼制作。我们的声音编辑是克里斯·康迪汉。感谢您的收听。代表美国心理学会，我是金·米尔斯。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。